c'est en 1955 à 19 ans quand richard
réalise son rêve jouer pour le canadien
et rejoindre son célèbre frère maurice
de 15 ans son aînée
sans avoir le tempérament incendiaire du
racket
henri richard est néanmoins un joueur
intense et malgré sa petite taille sa
hargne et sa détermination défie toute
forme d'intimidation
dès sa première saison celui que l'on
surnomme le pocket rocket remporte la
coupe stanley au sein d'une formidable
équipe qui allait répéter l'exploit cinq
années d'affilée de 1956 à 1960
travailleur infatigable le rapide joueur
de centre devient vite un des préférés
des partisans est l'un des meilleurs
joueurs offensifs de la ligue
[Applaudissements]
à sa troisième saison il finit au
deuxième rang des marqueurs avec 80
points en 67 matchs
henri richard ajoute six autres bagues
de la coupe stanley dans celle de 1966
où il marque le but vainqueur en
prolongation contre les grands rivaux
red wings de detroit capable d'élever
son jeu dans les moments cruciaux
il le démontre à nouveau en 1971 après
avoir traité son entraîneur armes etc ni
d'incompétents il enchaîne avec les but
égalisateur et vainqueur lors du
septième match de la finale contre
chicago l'automne suivant avec le départ
de jean béliveau henri richard devient
le nouveau capitaine en 1973 il mène le
canadien a une autre conquête de la
coupe stanley pour lui sa 11e ce qui est
plus que n'importe quel autre joueur
dans l'histoire du circuit en 1975
à 39 ans richards met un terme à sa
fructueuse carrière de 20 saisons avec
le canadien
pas mal pour un joueur que plusieurs
considéraient trop petit pour jouer dans
la ligue nationale
personnalité peu bavarde modeste henri
richard et le premier surpris lorsque
l'équipe décide en décembre 1975 de
retirer son chandail numéro 16
non j'ai hésité un peu qu'un monsieur
koala tu m'as demandé son accord pour
que j'aie était de la trempe de poids
d'un jambon
c'est chaud et p
après décision henri richard est ensuite
admis au temple de la renommée du hockey
des sports du canada est en fait du
québec comme l'avait été avant lui son
illustre frère maurice avons toujours
ici à vie henri richard tient pendant
longtemps le rôle d'ambassadeur du
canadien affectés par la maladie
d'alzheimer depuis quelques années il
disparaît peu à peu de la scène publique
l'une de ses dernières apparitions
remontant à 2013
lors de la cérémonie précédant le match
inaugural du tricolore françois faucher
radio canada montréal